Thank
you.
So
for one hour and 15 minutes
of
the last days
I'm
going to use a similar system on his face and I'm going to serve as a surrogate
less a.
So I'll,
I'll,
I'll ask them the questions and you will all line.
I'll assign a sliding door or a l I thought.
Oh
yeah.
Cool.
Um,
so it is customer and to
us better than him
and usually when is being introduced
to a speed.
Now of course you've all come there because
I'm.
So I'm going to do a different thing because I think it has thomas you more
deeply something about what is going on with his job.
So I'm going to read you a few things that are wrong about.
So these are actual things that are often media,
character assassination and there has been one each day just about for a long
time.
So is the times if he wants to force young women marriage,
these people
actually not that bad.
Okay.
So,
and that's the reason they say that they want you to become a grade
level group.
All right.
Of these
conservative reform listing with.
So that's another one,
the directors that
I,
I'm one of you as well as I go,
a coral is
formed,
is preferable
to say he's a scientists.
We encourage these young men to see themselves as he's a mash up of delivers a
Mashup of hits.
And my first book of myths,
we seems like a terrible therapist is in fact political and social thinker,
an angry white guy,
authoritarianism and Richard Spencer is that system isn't
used to do,
is chill.
He's attached with Mrs. This is just a small sample
and it's all wrong for have,
you know,
decided to go home and shield.
It's all wrong
and you want every day to miss informed people about that.
And you can demonstrate demonstratively false.
I would.
There are some people that see him as a risk to their agenda and their work with
you for some reason.
That is a reasonable balance,
walter,
with fruitful.
And I've never seen such a campaign against any thing ever in the world.
Uh,
not even some of them is untruthful or ask.
This is thing is.
So this tells you something,
this
tells you something about this importance of his message and I'm not gonna,
not gonna theorize about exactly what that is,
because there are lots of theories about exactly what it is in what you say
breakfast
and
actually
let's just listen to you and you have to figure out what happened.
So please give a warm welcome,
not be
thinking the other room
numbers
that there isn't anything more where your issue is issue,
then we're discovering numbers that
power
and
the claim numbers are
reading
to utilize them and your ability to operate in the world expands
when you use it.
The facilitator use of operating the world.
Interesting lead numbers are abstractions.
And so that raises another question.
Well,
what's more real?
The
yeah,
and maybe the question for me,
but it's not obvious that abstractions aren't real strong on anything else.
And so then you might ask yourself,
well then one of the most real
abstractions
start
tonight.
We're going to talk about in relationship with as many rules as I can.
No,
those were the rules.
First
is stand up straight.
Shoulders.
Back
to is treat yourself like you're someone responsible for
number three,
which is very tightly associated with
me,
is making friends with those people.
By the way,
these rules aren't designed to make your life easier.
His whole life.
Everything was seeding,
easily
cry out
world
as a universal benefactor that we would strive to do nothing other than to make
life more difficult for
someone to respond to me is the same as the nice to so it's not associated
with the best
for is you hear yourself yesterday
and that's Johnson.
That's easy.
You need,
you need things that are
worthwhile,
but that is
more.
It is deserved.
We're undeserving manner,
so as the target for improvement
and the rule of thumb there is if you dislike them,
that
is a bad idea.
To allow their children to act in a way that makes other children is like the or
adult is like they're going to have to deal with children and you're going to
have to be so.
Your primary responsibility is to how have your job or not behave so that the
world opens up its arms and well
managed.
That it's not a simple thing to do is protect your house,
is the perfect word in world and not take no action until you have activator.
We use that line,
your ambition and work on what's right in front of you that you will suffer for
it.
You didn't roll the large scale transformation of other people.
Seven is meaningful,
not scream and rant would say in some sense some sense that's
not telling the truth or at least necessary junkies necessary additional because
I don't think that you can pursue what is meaningful,
the truth and the reason for that is let's say why you corrupt the mechanisms,
mechanisms that
manifested itself meaning and then you can trust them.
That's a very bad idea,
so the fundamental reasons to not live
and when you grew up in rely on yourself and if
you lie on the absence of rule justin,
but nothing,
you be
just
that was it
than
the person that you're listening to.
Something that's not so much respect for the person that is a mark of
recognition of your own unbearable maintenance.
Now,
one of the things you have to do is decide whether
more
you have to make sense
more.
You have to decide what's more important.
First of all,
there's a lot of what you know and so if you restraints with that because that's
important,
well that's a good thing because you're going to be surrounded by your entire
life.
If you were appreciative of that,
absolutely make things better,
but
the other element of that is,
well,
why should you be appreciated as well?
You shouldn't be.
Your life is absolutely perfect in every way.
You have exactly what you needed.
One get ordered around in what you do is sufficient,
but if you believe that things can still be right around you,
your own
with regards to the effect you have another people,
it obviously wasn't built yet and it was more important than what you do know
and you should be paying us and find out at every possible moment and if you're
fortunate when you have a conversation with someone,
actually interested in what they say they haven't.
Even if they're not very good at communicating initiatives or awkward or even if
they display a certain amount of energy towards you is always the possibility
that they might tell you something you don't know,
in which case you could walk away from the conversation,
less ignorant and then it were when you started the conversation and if you
like,
isn't everything that you would like it to be the slightly less important and is
probably the thing and so ruth Pennington,
be precise and speak from that's in there and say that that's a barrier of a New
Testament in council,
which is a description of the nature of the world which is not being asked to
receive is very stringent theory,
let's say,
but I would say is far more in accordance with what we know about the psychology
of perceptions,
let's say than you might imagine because it is the case that
you don't get to delegate.
Now,
Mike,
if you do it in that and might is better as which the center,
if you specify the nature of the.
Actually,
if you specify the nature of the being that you want break into being that he
radically decreases the probability that that's her or she will know that
because you regard yourself at least to some degree as active creative agents,
fundamental attitude towards itself isn't afterwards is that you will have a
landscape of possibilities that leave themselves open to you and you make
choices.
The three no's and determined in consequence how the world is going to manifest
itself in a field of potential concern of your choices do determine which
elements of that are going to concretize them self into the real world are very
unhappy with yourself.
People will do a property and you're very unhappy with other people.
If they don't do that property,
you're going to have other people.
If they don't treat you like that's what your life,
because part of what you demand for people,
let's say in terms of sheer civility,
is that they act towards you lose.
If you're the locus of voluntary choice in the world and your brave each other
for that.
As children and parents,
your parents would say,
if you're fortunate,
you're not living up to your potential,
which is actually a compliment in a sense,
even though it's also a judgment and the problem is I know perfectly well that
you can be more than you are and you'll pay your bills done every single thing
like he thinks in relationship to your own conscience that yes,
I have a lot of brokers that are not fully realizing and that actually
constitutes state transgression against the group.
I don't.
I don't think I've ever met anyone who doesn't believe that if you have
reasonable conversations to seems self evident now and then you need someone
who's a narcissistic itself,
satisfying,
but then they're narcissistic.
That's not good at that as a medium to low third strategy.
That's a disaster.
You know?
It's a short term protecting.
Moreover,
it's not the least.
Of course,
other things as well.
Rule 11,
there's no father children in their state board and that's the discussion is
courage,
encouragement,
workforce specifically because I the standard,
for example,
what role parents play in the lives of their children.
I would say this is a little bit that is a fundamental importance as well as a
family to your children so that they act in a socially desirable manner so the
world opens itself up to them.
You also want to encourage them,
which is not the same as sheltering them.
It's not the same at all.
And to encourage the audience to say something like,
look accurate,
something like your kid
as you.
The world is already difficult.
It's even difficult or you're not the same.
Their child's size difficulties,
but they're still different.
Role is a very hard place and it's a better place and it's not only a hard
interface.
It's also tested the trailer and that's the fundamental bottom line,
but there's something in you that is capable of taking that on and transcending
and that's encouragement.
You'd say,
well,
as difficult as things are,
you are often the children and with children when you're doing that,
say in advisedly dangerous things,
which of course knew if their state border to interfere with that is to
interfere with the child's willingness to voluntarily expose themselves to the
risks that they need to expose themselves to in order to develop the competence
that allows them to thrive,
to grow the account,
sheltered from
interfere with children when they're taking the necessary risks is not love.
We're infinitely powerful is our parents and it's deeply down into children and
I can tell you that I've never had a client come to my office and all the
hundreds,
all hundreds of encounters have people in my office.
I've never had a client say,
my parents need me to be independent.
That hasn't happened with one right now.
My parents need me to dependent or life conspired with my parents to
perpetually.
That happened all the time.
So here's a rule of thumb that I think is a good word is often applied to
nursing homes by people who work at your
job.
And the rule is,
do not do anything for anyone they can do for themselves and the reason for that
extended support that
first of all,
if you do something and facilitates the movement forward,
then they move forward because you help
people as therapists that advice
it might fail in the shape they are.
Rooms paid for my advice,
and second,
if it succeeds,
then I get to be the successful one.
I don't want to steal the success for my clients.
That's a bad idea.
I want to help them figure out what it is that they should a map and then the
strategy for attaining now.
But I want to ensure that it's their destiny,
not something I'm in a position
I would say therapeutic relationship,
bad relationship here you right?
So one of the things you want to do with your departments,
your spouse,
you say your husband or wife and also children's to listen to them so that you
can figure out what their problems are and figure out which one is going to
figure that out by communicating and then perhaps aid them in the development of
the strategy.
You have to ensure very carefully that you're not imposing your own structure in
that,
going to steal from them what's there,
so it's a little evidence current as the fundamental is you can say what's the
antidote to the catastrophe life and what has to be safety.
If you're non sensible enough to know that a certain amount of tradition,
the safeties is worthwhile,
you should probably wear your seatbelt when you're driving in your car because
why he foolhardy breath,
but given that there is no security in the final analysis,
then encourage.
There isn't much better medication than sheltering and so and that's that's I
think the eating with the idea that what life is essentially is not a place to
be happy to aim for degree for some front of the wall now to,
but I called to something like adventure and I think that's the proper way of
conceptualizing it.
Certainly if you go watch a story and move,
do you agree to something like that?
If you encounter a narrative that's really literate,
romance or a classic adventure story is the element of this.
It's gripping is the adventure and so portray life is an adventure and romance
and properly and the way that we
facilitate the is to encourage them.
I have a five month already,
liked him,
was a good guy,
smart guy,
good guy and everything.
He was little.
He's a good musician.
Talented athlete.
Curve
will be bundles,
relationship with his girlfriend,
his girlfriend,
the other
gender,
and brought the birth parents.
They need every provision profitable to help her prepare for the jury that
invite the community to make sure she had a great
group and when you talked with his parents,
all he did was worried that he was to her and get her can get her,
but they didn't understand that they were choosing between the hurt,
but you might make to the world and you're having an adventure.
That's girlfriend.
The hurt that he would encounter by staying at home,
Howard in his basement,
protectionism or lobbying Paris,
last girlfriend.
Which of those two things is more damaging and their answers as his parents
wouldn't worry as much as it was in the basement.
Don't worry,
he's going to be more so I'm
going to count three,
the NIPSA
meditation on rigidity.
It's a discussion of what we do and what to do and that's really good to that.
Your personal life,
work life,
interview quickly.
It indicates of death in the
lots of degree or any of the things that we have your world outside now close
with a
discussion of necessity of nearly years.
These are more of a control perhaps of the days,
and these are really
our three minutes,
10 minutes.
Can we get
in front of Molly last time that
you do that on your blog,
you're doing not suffering away madly
appreciate everything manifests itself.
That allows itself to be appreciated.
And so that's the 12 rules and I'll return and the street music platform for
laying abstractions.
So some of other with the sense of doubt,
doubt,
doubt is a very extreme word,
easily translatable,
single meaning,
at least in English,
it means half of light so that the path as
the profit path so that the proper path.
So the idea that as a symbol of reality,
what does it needs to be enlightened?
So there's an implicit idea there that the fundamental reality life is the path
that takes you like it's not a materialist idea,
just different times.
It's the idea that life is more outreaches and we're on a journey,
best reconceptualize.
The reality is the place that you journeyed through,
what are the elements,
what are the constituent elements of the place that you journey through now
that's needed,
and yet in
the world,
the black Blackford again and again,
seven possibly gain from the fact that it's a symbolic representation,
doesn't mean women or men in art.
It's an attempt to use sexual symbolism who represent a deeper underlying
reality is massively in is dark night and there's a light
and the black law license,
one of the other red anymore.
And so that's the new
world.
And the question is perhaps address to use.
Well,
what exactly does that mean?
So it actually means something.
It's kind of abstraction and it's actually an incredibly powerful instruction.
Once you understand instruction,
it be the most real abstraction there is going to layout with on.
They offer you a little bit of
and then that they're real and they're going to tell you what it means
so
you kale now will pay off,
you know,
they often.
So one of the things that deal with this is something like
this is not how people think,
if you want to spray,
because it is how we act,
and as I said already,
you act as if you confront and you treat pencil out as if it's real and if your
attitude towards it,
converters on you a certain World Vision,
which is why you know what people need when they say you're not giving up,
no one ever says
no,
and very few people say,
Oh,
I'm fully living up to my remit,
is the reality that undergirds that consistent conception that makes that person
off ability
immediately.
She lives in the future.
That's part of it,
and we believe in the future.
We believe that it exists even though it isn't here and it's not measurable.
It's.
It only exists as a potential step up realizable often.
That's what the future is really well.
We're complaining with.
We don't really contend,
reorient yourself to future comes out direction,
just signed as part of and how you construct the French.
In the past,
our payoff is retention and that's the problem.
It's like if you're in a working,
is there another way of consensual I needed?
Do I have a of
another plan?
It's something that I got put into a power that was make this terrible situation
or that's all I have to call and use it to transfigure.
I'll eat this.
He told me he more because of the wager conceptualizing.
We need that.
I understand it himself so bad that there are basically done.
You have to do.
People obviously
got their businesses collapse and genuinely terrible things can happen to you
that aren't your fault,
that is not saying can just cheering them worldwide.
That's pretty cool,
but I understand that you have a tremendous ability to transform the landscape
of possibilities in front of you and then when things are terrible,
that's your best bet.
Doesn't see just these.
You don't have a better option,
and so her pencil is also something that a terrible manner.
So imagine this.
This is really thinking about,
so imagine that you have a relationship,
let's say American now,
the rear one trust and available us,
and that's the trust and fidelity is the action of your memories.
Like,
well,
let's lay it out for 10 years,
and then your wife tells you that she has had three affairs,
each of them the last three years and the last one a lot this year.
So then what happens?
Then
what happens is that everything you thought was wrong,
right?
And this is such a disrespecting thing actually been in the past.
The past is
there.
All the sudden you find out that one of the things that you thought of the past
that was very important thing wasn't true at all,
and so work on meeting a whole task that you thought was was it wasn't what it
was.
It all so it transforms itself from a nationality is pretentious and most of
them is native listener.
The need
for your marriage is dreadfully unhappy and you're just looking for an excuse to
me.
It's possible that that revelation,
even though it was shocking,
we will come with the spirit is released,
so this repetitive professional manifest itself even when it's unexpected,
it doesn't necessarily manifest itself in India.
Got will also breed.
If one thing to that
and the trail was revealed and the divorce,
can you set yourself up to two years?
My work,
it's not a pathway on written saying
that's the introduction of the board and he need the oldest story that we have
is something like order is susceptible to disruption by payoffs and human.
The fundamental demands made on the human being is to contend with the chaos
that is not work,
not just in order to not pretend that the chaos is to encourage your children,
for example,
what you're doing is encouraging you to become the masters of the chaos that is
is an order is made some his of payoff,
which makes them not as important.
You train your children,
encourage your children and yourself and your partner from having sense to be a
master of detail
and so
so this,
this rough,
disruptive.
It's the infinite world to disrupt your financial considerations.
That's another way of looking at another way of looking at it is it's the
serpent in the garden of Eden and the reason that that story is set up the way
it is because it's trying to represent that there was no place so bound and data
secure.
Even if it's set up my blog himself,
it doesn't have an agent of chaos inside.
It's exactly the same idea,
but now here there's some more representation.
It's just
the question is,
well,
what we do in regard given the sustainment and that's something like master the
snakes,
so and that's a neat idea.
That's the same idea as
sitting on the ocean rescue water from the belly of the whale.
The same idea and that's an l greatest stories is your gross
manifests itself together.
Something as a consequence to the sure is there isn't a story that's more
emblematic of what a nice event that that.
That is a.
that's our best bet.
All right,
so nails.
You don't.
It's a task that need to suddenly enter your left,
the office,
the flood.
It's definitely become ever present possibility.
Apocalypse in your personal life,
in your community.
Like in the
refinery,
virgility existing in a world that's beyond me,
off his potential lies before cause I need something can rescue yourself from
seeing orders,
permanent element,
the existence.
Chaos is what you don't know.
What's outside the fire
walls,
walls of your town,
outside of the borders of your passion.
All of that is hail
or
order is where you are.
What you're doing is working any matter.
It's very specific.
How do you know that you know what you're doing when you don't because you don't
know everything.
Everything you do is my ignorance,
but you still have to operate in the world.
This is what we do is make finite plans and then plans,
maybe sap strategies to make those kinds manifested itself and if the consultant
the way that you desire in any regard to knowledge,
so that's your difference between truth and it's the only definition you can use
because you don't have everything at hand and when you're aware of is working,
that's word and you might think why should just stay there?
Because that's a comfortable place to be and there's a certain truth except for
one thing if you
word and you stand in it and wait,
the disorder itself because things aren't stacked,
things change all the time.
You're finding yourself in a static structure is definitely trail because
everything around you is blocks and the thing that's permanent rule transform
itself.
Here's an example.
Let's say you're a perfectly well.
We'll have a new rule you actually with.
That's none of your children.
Children,
that's
very mature form of children.
They can be really delightful people to have like three years maybe paint them
the reason
they hit puberty,
which is the emergence of hail off into the,
into the bowl,
ready to go through the emergency sexuality in the descriptor that didn't have a
deficit progression.
Do you ever get shot off the things?
Always do.
It's know where to turn 16.
You're no longer is like 11 year old.
Very immature 16 years and the reason that I got out was because just because
somebody is now
five years from now and so in order to be stable,
you're not the same thing.
The dynamic not static,
so you have to be very large bowing to where you're going and this opinion,
both African,
so it's stability,
plus parents permission and manifest in your narrative,
meaning that's actually the instinct meeting,
which is an instinct to perhaps the precisely the instinct that tells you who
are sufficiently stable.
You transforming yourself at a sufficient rate up with everything.
It's changed and you know that because if you're at your job,
you to say yourself,
well,
my job is really secure,
but it's not very challenging.
You think that it's very secure and that's it's not challenging.
It's in the sense that the spirit goes out of it.
If it's not challenging,
you need to be challenged and why Israel?
We've answered as well.
Tomorrow's how and whoever you now this is enough for tomorrow,
and so today you also have Laura and next week and next year,
and if you're challenging and it isn't doing that for me,
and you find the need,
and the reason for that is that it's sliced your most essential instinct.
Instinct is the instinct for meaning and it signifies that it actually seemed
balanced,
right?
We right,
which is why it's fundamental open space paying us,
nor are the most real things.
Alright,
so you have the payoff.
It's not in scope and then he's not the order that you,
your mastery.
Let's take order.
We're thinking about the structure order and I'm not saying,
I'm not saying that at all.
That's the balance,
the balance.
Even as important in this category,
whether you liked development,
their fundamental constituent elements of reality.
You might say,
well,
what's your evidence for that?
And it can tell you one piece of evidence for very much time.
You have content experience needs to be great
was your
world.
Your brain is the adaptive world,
let's say fundamental strategy meeting structure and the bifurcation indicates
that filed medical reality
divided four
and if you're working deposition reality is scientific,
biological
reality that shapes
early perspective and they like bifurcated representation of life.
It's a proper.
We never did reality and perhaps the real itself is
a nice logical evidence.
American.
You left spirit,
specialized operations in those situations that you know and understand and
you're right when the spirits
in those situations that united no nor understand and the proper way to sell our
was to be balanced operations.
Correct.
The way that manifests itself in different experiences as meaningful,
so that's not an APP first path.
What will you say?
Justification for the that these two
are the most real domain order over.
Now,
if you just sit there and who is that?
What we think?
Why will suffer and die?
That's what will happen.
So without actually apart deterioration in death,
we meet at
last
3 billion years of evolution.
The action actually move in the face of necessity is quite
rewarding that
you have to know
that you have to have some.
You need some water.
Do you need some show that you need some kind of
sexual partner
way?
Actually nee nee people grinding way those same people across God you sins are
necessary.
Well as survival itself.
Assumptions just sitting there.
It's not the right
word,
not in world.
The Internet stops you from deteriorating guy at minimum and not being able to
address the problems that are a Jersey for about now of 800 are in water.
Sewage.
The loan to the jurors is specialized.
Bottom hole,
you can bless it and afraid.
She suffers pain,
almost a special assistance for all both you and your correctional systems
orientation world and they have to figure out what to do so when you're hungry,
it's time,
it's
time to seat belts.
You have specialized system where there aren't enough because
that's
the problem with organizing.
It's like,
well not the complaint.
You have to do something,
a little shelter and there is right now for the next two years from now,
five years from now,
so you have to have stretches of time now in the future you,
this new family and the community,
it's all done has to be taken into account in your movement for very,
very close to Salt Civil Paisley and your motivational.
50.
Anger,
hunger and so forth can help them solve those problems now,
but not all of them.
Permanent hire.
All of our complex problems.
How do we propagate the game across
the left hemisphere operates we embarrassed when work.
It's hard work like senior right hemisphere off.
People don't like it going on accident,
but it's the whole native emotion,
the whole pain and anxiety.
It's the thing that turns on I deeply did not expect if the terrorism onslaught
of what we do
now because used the right hemisphere in condition,
standard
artistic expression for all sorts of things you like so because it's also
possible in the interim
should you have to do is I'm going to
use something.
You have to do some definitional issue.
This is an act out the proposition that the thing you're doing,
Z is preferable.
You have and we'll do it for those things.
You're trying to get
tangled.
Say I'm eating,
but I don't know.
There's something wrong with the way you conceptualize that mistake because we
did something and bring it into existence is the same as johnny and say,
well,
that has been something because either your academic or you know what you're
talking about.
It's more
confused that your action patterns and the girls health representation,
but that doesn't mean that they're critics of just means that people use so
after an awkward suffer in order to add value because much more than the Nata,
which means happy topic of value,
so we just start dying because it's
not
socially
pursued.
Aims in isolation because you're not not a solitary animals and your title and
deeply private families,
communities,
our society and social.
Every.
No,
as long as we been Fridays,
so maybe that's.
That's at least six years and it might be more like $60 million.
It's really all time.
So it's not an arbitrary social construction.
Now what happens start
to hire.
He
Watch,
let's say one thing is doing that.
Enough happens me
to do anything besides already promoting healthy things done and then you get
whatever comes to me and the first thing he did around whatever.
So and that is
insane and
people would ask me
one visual landscape,
something double back
in Cleveland for a good activity.
There's actually a law price's law and it's a real law.
He's governed size,
the massive star and just of cover covered price's law says that the square root
of the number of people engaged in it,
the pricing.
So if you have 10 absolute
candidate and if you have 10,000 in a how did this work and that you know how
well the series itself such that a minority people have more money.
80 five richest people in the world,
they have it.
It's something like that and everybody goes from my boss and one percent it's
like,
well first of all girl,
one percent.
So
yourself
speaking and by current standards and certain binders,
you're all even one percent.
So if that's a problem,
well it's a problem for all of you might be,
you know,
Richard is app.
That doesn't mean all in the same boat on the fact that wealth NCA to enhance
the cable is part of the general expression.
There's nothing special.
You see the same thing every creative building in.
How many of you have recorded a
full record?
How many?
Five?
Zero
one.
So there's one of the and that's one 10th of one percent.
Something like that.
How many of you have
a date on obtaining?
Is Hanging in national says here,
look
how many of you will be member of a professional sports team
when we get the point here?
Okay,
so it was like,
and so the rule
system that you use and it doesn't know me well enough.
It's like,
well here's something else
started with guardian is an intrinsic
deep
suffering and you train itself,
so that's the baseline.
That's intolerable.
Anyways,
he was involved and immersed in digital.
What we do with the base of something and you try to find something to justify
having something that gives him the hell in the morning and not just any old
one,
but I'm more with your water,
has Alzheimer's disease and your daughter have you need something to get out of
bed for girls more than this two and half.
The purpose,
that
purpose is going to be such that it better be a damn noble purpose because
otherwise why important and so
that's of sufficient tension,
let's say,
or valuable position.
So worth suffering for because you're going to stop and you better have
something that needs the suffering.
Justify its structure,
period
when the flood comes in your life and certainly we'll build that will sustain
for the catastrophe.
That's not this pursuit of happiness.
It's not even your.
None of them is your orientation that we managed
to hire.
It's so high that it's worth bearing the burden of being reduced
you implement out of Ireland now say,
well,
and then it got higher priorities.
Apparently people are going to be very good at.
There's that higher desk and then you have the second girl admire when I asked
you stick out your knee pain and they were very,
very unlike.
I'm not saying people all day
extraordinary there and that's an inevitability.
As soon as you decided something were doing,
these people start
to take would be or observed
almost everybody else.
What is the problem?
Like IRA
attendances,
disintegration or most people bought and so that's the next thing,
the hierarchies,
because if going to
die,
you didn't want to die,
solution
will have the problem the higher and it's almost higher.
Most people now typically agree with the lions.
Have something to say.
That's what they say,
and then look at that very carefully and he can say,
that hasn't been a hierarchy itself or or we just finished.
It doesn't mean you have no more issues
to deal with that when it's actually in a way to deal with.
That was the hardest political factor is that right?
The deals with hierarchy,
the department,
this cost,
so one of the things that you can reliably assume about someone's right is that
they will be patriotic in favor of the current higher or being more.
That's exactly the only new hire.
It's up in.
More people will be higher,
so patient support.
The people who are dispossessed by Harvey and when you have to say is,
yeah,
we actually do something,
most app,
anything like that.
The answer is no because there's no permanent solution to the problem of his
possession by the higher.
We don't know how to fix it.
Say,
well,
hire north slope.
That's a price to pay,
but we can take from the top at the bottom.
It's like
yes,
hypothetically,
good
practice.
It's very,
very easy to go too far and then what we ended up with is less dispossessed.
You ended up with no one who has anything that's
scarcity,
right?
They were equally debt or start with,
which is essentially what the states did cross the entire 20th century is not
the proper way to address.
The higher there has to be addressed.
Awesome.
For you,
this is a
mirror
system so they can stay there and without
children
or they can a higher becomes corrupt so that people who own theory and power
compliant,
it's just our
title,
which looks like a theory because there's all sorts of
weight
also.
If the higher steam that everybody stacks up with zero and you one can apply it
to basic definition of tyranny,
they don't have to write the thing,
the spring game because we're already at zero,
so we're going to help me not to lose.
And so one of the things that you want to do if you're a sensible concern of it,
is making sure that the hierarchy,
the gains,
it's Ruthie competence is transparent and it's likable.
You can otherwise equal ossify and Steven and then it will destroy itself and if
you're a conservative,
you know,
stability and the hierarchy set up a situation where the tire itself so promote,
you can say,
well,
don't
you think Walter's
lonely is the hierarchical structure itself as a feature of existence,
at least a third of a billion years old,
which means that you cannot attribute.
Listen,
the free market or the corrupt patriarchal blessing
pasted all three of those elements contributed to existence on the stations
as
Nike is actually directed towards the left.
If you want to help this dispossess don't really exist in supplier is on.
Capitalism has it's wrong,
it's wrong.
That is way cheaper than mountain.
Here's something else to
consider.
So we are spectacular.
Dwelt
first in class or Iceland,
more wealthy than 100 years ago.
It's absolutely awesome.
And so that's the first passenger west exponential growth started.
You really,
really thought first announced faculty of the world.
I don't know his people.
Um,
you went and set a goal to have
it
ready will ever report we obtained in 2000,
12,
three years ahead of the most optimistic record.
So people are lifted on greatness,
has never been
broken,
divided
with fruit,
with access to the first one.
Why did you have access to medications?
Going deeper?
What would probably be like kiss?
It's.
There are so many things in business so fast we cannot even believe it.
And here's
as far as the data,
we have the operation of the free market system which does inequality.
That's the thing,
but as far as I can tell,
the system that has every well and as long as it's every system produces
inequality,
but only system we know that cruises,
for instance,
adding,
holding the remark so when you're forever left and right,
how many units of inequality it as well,
and if the answer is zero,
then once you're outside the appropriate date,
that's the romance.
And if you try to impose that will be his name.
There's the price we paid for.
Well,
is it important?
Now,
that doesn't mean that you've committed to this extreme.
On the other phone,
it's just the whole thing,
what happens,
all the data,
lay it out and zero,
zero,
one person.
Now complaints.
The advocacy states his specialty is needed because there's a fair bit of chance
or the awkward world,
but the logical conclusion from the hierarchy,
the complaints is that one person has everything and everyone's not.
Obviously that's fine,
so,
so you know when they're awake.
In our society
we have progressive tax.
Hold
on real quick before I get another way of rectifying that people will have on
game,
right?
For Society,
we are many many things people can play and so if you're a lawyer in a,
if you can run small restaurant,
it was a diversity of age and so that's a good way of allowing of increasing
robustness and consistent so that you don't get higher
instigated roses perhaps it's an intractable problem.
It says one of the things from the end
station,
the war will be business always.
What's that in reference to?
It's also in reference to the Napkin and happens to be an economics
of everything from those things.
Everything will be taken.
That's the structure of the world and he can't lay it at the feet of progress.
It's the structure of the world.
Now.
That means we have to contend with is a part of the reason that we haven't
continued political file and that we need to have
is to make sure our hierarchies exist.
Maybe attack the Rock and being elected to that,
but that means the left has that higher level necessarily,
but valuable in the past will,
despite your necessity as a tenant,
the stack people up at the bottom.
You see that in
you see that the old testament because one of the things that happens when you
in the state and empire status,
six times the machine off stuff and then is corrupt.
It loses the way it is.
Balancing things,
the kidneys,
so the people and then forgetting your relationship with God.
That's another way of thinking and then it says you are paying enough attention
to the widows and the more you better thought and these devices in their
narrative thing that what's going to us
and so they don't take the steps necessary.
Corrective by here,
deviation from the path and they absolutely flattened and the consequences of
that last generation,
but second generation and then struggled growing up in something approximating
empires test again.
It's exactly the same thing happens.
We forget and we collect stories
by the Canadian literary people
to break them so there's no such
thing as a nice adjunct,
so so,
so that's the nature of who are ordered chaos and order.
Your goal is your relationship.
If you do that by meeting a lot more expedient,
that's safe,
ensure that you have the third property by taking his life.
You want to pat all the instinct that orients in the world and you will have
engaged,
engaging with the sea and the reason you do that,
we just practice something.
We build structures that specialize in math and any level of it.
So if you're living a lie,
this is very thing to do and you're building neurological mechanisms that go
through that lie and once they're built,
they're you.
And good luck.
Undoing
the Parker House
is built.
Negativism surf
for and those systems are alive.
All they want is to grow up and they're not,
it's not psychological.
It cycled as he was.
Don't build structures and prohibition predicated on deception because you will
pay that and so if you're going to guide your life with the orientation of the
instincts that meaning you have to be very careful what we say and write.
The thing is every time you say or write with and something,
you build the little girl that specialized to that and they participates in this
of the world.
So right.
Chaos.
Or is it higher is here's the next book
is order a higher.
The subsidiary questions will be the hierarchy.
What's.
Well,
I don't live off of the hierarchy.
The hierarchy does not want what to be down.
So
the first thing I could see his orders not at Meijer.
What are the same?
That's a different thing.
So
I take a job
and a job briefing.
Soccer?
No,
my son is still pretty good.
Rena,
just down the street
there.
And so it's sort the kids into these games and if team was getting skunked flap
or any other things winning too much and then rebalance the teams so that they
are equal in skill.
So that was the sliding fees.
So
and then we're on the way it behaves during
one.
And
so when my son was deep within,
I think it was the championship game correctly and there's one kid on his team
who was the best player
very fast on his feet because he gets to
eat.
But um,
that's problem.
One problem was he wasn't passed on now to talk with you pretty much answer as
well,
but you want to be the best person on the team
and you want to read the,
my boss wants to walk.
Maybe your team mates,
band player.
How's that?
Maybe you want to meet the people on the team player.
I did a little bit too far,
but she certainly want to make your teammates better plan anyway,
I think we'll want to do that because bad people.
Well,
that's at world because first of all,
if you ran across the contribution around you,
is that a little better and it's a helpful way to win by making everyone else
load.
It's not much of a victory and so we passed the damn pop,
especially who,
especially you.
So you've got a comfortable lead.
Well then maybe risk taking time to wait for that specific game to build up the
confidence in the ability of the and then maybe every leader they make your not
even so much because you're the best for but because why not?
Okay.
So once again we're pretty excited,
real close and it's like three to three and it's a minute lap.
Another to you.
This in stores really cool.
And so my son speed limits except that they were in the championship and it was
a pretty good thing.
So you know whether or not they lost.
It's not lost.
Hey,
you know,
here's the broader integration.
Okay,
so this
one for the scenario because as far as I'm concerned,
he was
useless.
Teammates who is helping,
correct.
What is fair,
who had helped those idiots farther rushes over to him.
And his loss and supports have been this notion that he was wrong and I thought
you,
yeah,
way more
than he had a son who was a star.
Then she had a son who is in good versus.
Yes,
absolutely you gave the wrong choice.
He sacrificed in some school,
in part,
she helped them save face for game that's not acceptable.
So here's what you tell them to tilt.
It doesn't matter if you indicate that's what the production side of it and
better knowing what it meant.
But who knows what that means.
If you tell a joke or not and maybe they're going to walk again,
go,
you're an alien
lg right out because obviously,
and he got mad with you.
So what does it mean?
Say that.
And what do you mean by that?
And Go,
well,
I don't know what it needs,
but it's a good thing.
So what do you mean by that?
Here's grabbing me
a little bit.
Because other people would just like to dislike.
Unless you walk.
The children who have a goal for everyone,
dislikes them.
Don't let the children
take retention so that other people will punish them because you don't have the
discipline.
People don't find that.
A lot of people make time for it,
so
let's take that apart.
The first thing is ms dot Garcia's hierarchy in order to hire their answer is
no,
it's a fire or it's the set of all possible.
However you guys do in a society time.
There's higher that transforms the hierarchy,
the civics and the hierarchies.
Jane,
the fact that the higher rebate,
and so you've been in hierarchy as a structures to a multitude of possible
higher that's going to change.
His life continues and so what were your children is not even master's out
higher than you want them to,
children's to be the master of the sand,
the whole possible higher ed.
Then no matter how things change their rate,
see,
well,
how is it for things to change?
Answer this way so that people will invite you to play.
Right?
There's the Google Group for children raising children is really rule.
One of the things.
This is something who's present,
who's been anointed
to agendas.
It's really good for children to play Nice.
First of all,
if you have children in play because you know that they asked us,
they will rough and tumble play with you until you are completely exhausted and
they're not even.
They explained
it to push to the edge,
so I knew this new fondant harvest is the pacer gs and
perhaps a little more quiet people.
He wrote a book called Athletic Neuroscience.
He just started placer in separate places
and he didn't want to work on graphs and showing that in order to social life.
So far it hasn't been in compliance and here's the cool thing,
I guess in some instances postmodern to peak of the patriarch of purity,
so you've taken into combat menial ended up.
You give them an opportunity to apply
the next time that you bring to the same place.
You can measure how much work they'll open the floor to
say work or how hard.
I'll decide street spring to the panel and so we can get an estimate of the
nation because playing harder work and that's really hard.
So
one
issue.
So that's over the place.
Now let's grab a run rate is 10 percent the Hubbard and that really me people
getting
in
the parking lot,
so now really been little stuff.
If you think that moved for healing,
Marvin and he like
walked into the fear is going
to
and don't have kids.
Ten percent
skirt
because that one
little thing.
No wonder you're not psychopathic individuals wondering nicely,
they know
the rules for playing someone's 30 times or not the with playing someone
so plate repeatedly and what have you observed in your time together in
situations?
Little different little that comes bouncing ball.
So now is your number.
You lost.
You have to preach this complaint.
That's now big.
That's all.
Yep.
I don't think so.
To start studying my absolute miracle
that divergence doesn't.
He about to play even harass.
It's so basic.
It doesn't even human that is deeper than human.
It's real and it's epic.
It's interesting interaction and it's not just the that would seem so no.
Chimpanzees is blue,
pink and they're really,
really strong six times and sprawled with nail
fungus growing up and that happens is people have just passed.
It's like gym
and this is interesting girl,
and so getting discovered in the 1974 chips are tribal.
It improv over
territory and there's a river that's the payoff and our chimpanzees is habit.
The Kale or the chimpanzees and the juvenile patrol,
the perimeters is your support by fire.
For Jim to have them,
if they have a sense of quantity.
If five chairs
pits,
I actually knew that literally that's the CPG and gyms
and they will eat them alive.
So there isn't a lot of empathy.
Think about when you think about the
direction and you might think and like,
yeah,
maybe it's your contents and it's something else.
Men,
he,
we'll start wondering very,
very rapidly
so you have to score.
You're absolutely
horrifying book.
So read it.
So
just the gym's creatures and so let's look at a gym.
Basically
how
moving the ball in that gym and then my feet water to answer the most powerful
tyrannical
rule is how
that happens.
You know what happens to tyler juice?
They had an off day and to subordinates you each gang up to make a one and a
half super gimp
right?
So here's the gym tyrants need gloved hands,
so how do you never yourself as Jim,
if you want to be at the IRA and have preferential access to our announcer,
is engage in mutually reciprocal interactions with your peers.
The chance to stay here,
stay with me,
are the ones that have friends that are rolling through the permanent as Asian
Pacific,
but also be mailed and so have you been involved with chimps,
patriarchal utility,
a and beans locked
situation,
and so that speaks to a broader edtech is sacred,
that you can see this sort of thing throughout the Amazon thing is seems to
stabilize social as is now.
Maybe the simple avenue,
the Lord's prayer,
but we're doing simple and the idea that our higher radical patriarchy,
which is a word that nobody thinks her cheap camera reviews,
passion that comes from the idea that a that are hierarchies of radical which
they aren't,
and it can be done that way and being the most reliable,
nice to obtaining status to see how hard it is to be expressions of power and
both of those things are wrong.
They're wrong.
Nonetheless,
that's the theory of the flashes in the community.
Not that we haven't have to be honest that none of that's sufficiently
sophisticated is honestly super reasonable explanation of the work.
So we should.
All it's doing is dividing us into drive and it's not sold that.
It's hypothetical.
So
yeah,
you're saying that's
not what life is.
Not
a sequence of the same.
These sequences on different things and if you want to be a successful player in
the set of multiple different days in Ohio or ethnic and you build subordinate,
not ethic to piggeries anyone game,
you know,
so when you put
your victory each is and the reason that this is the best possible for you is
that you get invited a number of pain.
And so let's
see.
So let's say you want the best for task yourself.
Well,
I'm not going to be around forever and they're going to have a lot of different
people,
single people,
individual groups with people,
children and adult.
And what they have to be prepared for is to interact with people in the best
offer for them to say you're to.
People said
it.
Be shared reading or not share in any technical deliverable.
Three,
it's hard to move here
for data sharing,
like learn like she's engaging with your parents and what is it?
What is it?
It's your job when you're socializing.
A child was to before bed is for me is the attitude of the time.
Therefore they might give up as it isn't going to happen in the literature on
antisocial behavior.
Children is crystal clear on this point.
If your child was not for
sale,
beautiful.
After the psychologists and sociologists
have tried for like six days to figure out are anti social behavior in older
children and adolescents show they have managed
or is pushing
up your job person that other children want to play,
the reason you want
primary
and so if your children are accepted,
then you're on the way with other children,
with a parent,
but I'm easy to find there is represented
and they start.
You reciprocate reciprocally,
socialize quite.
It's a little bit better job of really played companions.
Then you could just stand back and you have to be around when something breaks
down and the system doesn't work.
When you haven't been here as a resource,
but basically for first of all it was going say,
you know,
you know what is so glad and have asked for it,
so you're trying to make your child's maximum weight on the world made up of a
sequence of higher parents score and so if you want the child could be the sort
of person who's invited to participate in what our higher self
and how much the child might do that.
Well,
they have two separate will take turns right?
You have to find out what other people want to be.
They want to play too sophisticated ethical rules before know if you're playing.
If they are planning for what are they like?
If somebody doesn't follow the airplane,
one and emotional person,
they revert to the behavior of the little two year old temper tantrum diversity.
Here's the crash on the floor.
It's not funny because we played.
If you don't lose them nice and no one else.
Different winds to help with someone like that
and that's all know any stamps has been put up with that.
Like if they find out their potential partner is a two year old,
he's war,
they just stop and go find another gig because that's exactly what happened.
Want that again and make sure that they're better to never let them loose in
anything.
They don't get any prior.
Well,
I want it
long.
You don't want it.
You don't like your kid is unsophisticated manner.
That's not the same thing on the other.
Had the
back back.
You shouldn't be no.
Right.
So you might take apart.
What does it mean?
Superbowl.
Repeat again.
And then walk down.
It was
already built into the interaction that we all are.
What are we getting?
Really understand her though.
So imagine you're watching a wall
to that
way.
Right?
And so.
No,
no,
that's fine.
Why did you pass
out now
the reason
why they want to
pass down until
they don't want to find it because
that
way
it's
written down.
So
what happens if the wall was where all the breath,
the whole
why
people weren't
allowed to eat
and so basically say is
not useful.
Useless.
Most.
Yeah.
So
I know what I will
do
my status,
and he gets ball hunting the next day.
So you might think,
well let's proceed with the loyalty that is don't care this next year of the
preacher that's wrong.
And then you might say,
well that's the rule that will call it that strong,
have rules.
The
rule say actually
what they're doing with the rules.
That's how we got our rules.
That's how our rules we have to know.
And then in walks and then in stories.
That's what our religious stories are,
the consequences as watching what the academic and then transporting that into
the store and continue on that story adds to the story of good decisions.
Let's say
why do you want to watch that sport?
Because you want to know how to at the descended from the gates and that's what
that story and as the movies or books or religious narratives are about,
that's where everything is at a rigorous level and the reason is because that's
what the world is native and that's what we need to know so that he might be.
So here's something to think about.
I'll give you the symbolic participation,
so there's this idea of Christianity not talking about this from a religious
perspective.
I'm talking about this Andrew,
the last
four games,
so there's this idea of in Christ he is the king of pain.
He's running to take that part so that you have a higher whatever it is and
they're so unhappy to talk,
so that's the first half is necessary.
The problem with that higher mission to tell a story about how the best talking
to your team,
like what we were doing the best.
I know you're over here,
maybe it's hockey,
soccer,
plumbing,
law,
business.
Our goals are and the thing that's after 12
out
as something that's whatever is the department across of things that are at the
park.
This is
normal and he wanted to steal some character to
character and you want a good good.
Sheriff says,
if you don't want to just tell a story about some guy named
John.
Woke up at six and then he said four times in 20 times
and walked into the bathroom.
You know how to move your mouth off.
Dysplasia.
Good
ingredients,
good across a bunch of people and you want him to abstract.
The summons was evil.
This is directly across a bunch of evil character.
Good character is the bigger than life.
One thing I
learned from
the entire Monday her,
when you picked up the whole entire group into groups of candidates
who people,
then you say,
well,
we're going to average across most app with the opposite Google Person Dato's
goals 10.
Let's say there are thousands
out of anything.
I'm just asking what the still images.
Maybe get
one.
What that one is,
what's applicable across the entire set and ask people.
That's a design thing.
That's what it is and so the Christian is Christ paid me be diesel vehicles.
Across the cross is the place where suffering is accepted.
The Cross is the dove and that's the Scott,
so there's an idea
of the cross earth is the center of the universe.
It's look goal and you see this bigger staring down at you.
That's the thing and that's how it behave in the world.
That's what that represents and faithful with.
Nice.
Well,
here's a way of unpacking this is associated associated with use of how is the
data.
Yeah.
Well,
we
certainly not say that the way to the wall is our
resource.
I'm not even saying that a little bit
say,
well,
isn't that a clerical staff is,
well actually no,
and I'm ready for
this.
This is what happens
with this stance is I'm willing to take less.
The world throws at me right now.
That's
what's scaring the hell off the street right here with stances.
While
volunteering
represents willingness to take on.
The
best possible strategies have been successful
is the fact that we both
sat down
and
you see
these.
They will be world will be
more
work.
That's why I don't know.
That's.
That's great.
That's it's the same place center you same idea.
You're secure.
That's you have tradition and the the civilization behind you and you have one
day off.
That's not enough
and against the is nice
and you can use that as a guy and it's an eight neurological instincts.
It's not something as denominator most real thing or is far as I can tell and
associated with certain
ventures,
courageously unknown.
Book yourself on the line.
He mentioned risk yourself ball.
Apparently you haven't any
great because you're in it's own way.
There's no else that isn't death.
Exactly.
Would be able to speeding up what the candidate is.
Choose how to confirm it,
so rule one is the standard experience.
He told us that,
and it has thing so amazing.
This is a kind of ultimate reality idea.
Position yourself properly.
You might say,
well,
let's
make her hurt estimates in person,
or
then you say,
well,
what's the fundamental realities of life?
And say,
well,
the suffering and the level
two course
black,
it'll be true.
It's not.
It's not the finance,
despite the fact that that's the ability of the human spirits and prevail is
more powerful than people.
That's the fruit.
You know that first of all,
know that because you're ashamed that
you don't have people learn.
Some people who manifests courage is dire straits and you know what?
I've lost.
Just need people like that and you're not like that.
They,
she speaks to the deep as possible and they know what we can be and you don't do
it.
You see people in situations,
but it's so difficult that it's truly a miracle.
It can condense,
nor I think of people who work in beautiful.
That's a good example.
That's hard,
right?
That's in brief every day and it's not something that uses voice.
It's like it's right there.
It's just really impossible to be
and
sleep all the time.
Freedom
that
Gypsy told that
after
childbirth is something I've never seen anyone else
unless you been
exposed to
what they're afraid of
children,
the children,
if that makes me stronger,
if you have post traumatic stress,
the victim of sexual assault by a stream disorder,
the most effective treatment is to get you to relive the experience as much as
possible out of experience,
and if you do that
can be buried in the world statement and
it sounds as avoiding something.
Voiding.
Break it into manageable pieces and how it therapy expose themselves to it and
be able to hear and that's the dragon.
In the clinical practice,
what do you most want to?
What most people would probably go right to help the state.
So she was three and I thought
was
very neat
story,
a stroke,
Rehab.
Anyways,
I said,
well,
I can
play it for awhile.
I'm not,
you come up with the rural from.
So uh,
he came back and she said,
I want to see an involving
is.
And she had his
story.
He said,
no problem.
She was very,
very imperative.
Not New.
Any problems we,
you know,
art and it's your ground.
I'll take law that's that need instead of going to be useful for them and error
experience with a new appreciation for life.
Well
that would come to the library.
It seems like dogs.
So with this room and watched this,
I'm apt to move from the smaller three person operation and got her
house.
She is inside.
I got here and I certainly can't.
She
take them all black.
And then
she was spending more time watching less tiny way I think.
Well she was fine because now watch it.
At some point you asked that you could,
even if what she did it,
she was like,
well,
so what did she discover?
What was important
to us,
and she didn't discover this depth was terrifying because it was,
what was you with the hell off comprehension and much quicker than she was.
And she went away thinking,
oh,
that I did the thing I was most afraid of doing your animals.
Not only am I not more damaged than reverse,
I'm actually better than it was.
And so from then on she got up reference point,
which is an interesting to.
I think this is why I'm initiate first dance
extraordinary young into something absolutely terrified,
genuinely terrified.
So for the rest of your life,
they know the difference between what's actually terrifying must just sort of.
Because you really need to know that because you need to go and work with
patients versus conferences
she could prepare like reality.
Like
most people I example avail,
despite the real life with Belle
arte reverse best.
So you don't have a story real.
That's
all right.
See,
through the whole group,
if you even have
representation from the Ngo community,
where do you see drop on some open.
I'm gonna ask
each forest
gardens
if you were to
stand up straight shoulders.
Hmm,
the darkness,
please
consider
me
the same idea
with the spirit,
the highest
possibly just
take
on the world
wars
against
your own art,
so when you go to slide though.
Nice.
Very cool.
Well,
you have
a question.
Thank
you.
Everyone
seems
this.
Well,
the next one is
the
call.
Somebody is reacting,
exposure resolved.
Seniors,
the
line producer,
there's regular
tall
are
anger,
so
he need to be necessarily.
I think that
fear
around what
we're
being
punished for your face.
It's so
minimal
and so built up.
Then instigate
deeply
unhappy,
not depressed
people
necessarily.
You think
that's the other thing
is
that certain states and then to see
doing
political background,
at least you
got the.
The people who are on the market,
conceptual IPA is political in their world.
There isn't one of the things that weren't considered food.
You are
have receipt for
what really is.
Here's something that you've
collected this perspective.
There is no such thing.
That's
not that they oppose it.
It isn't a movie
this,
so if you stand up and say
that's not acceptable moving because you are,
you're an hour of the dominant group and whatever you awkward regardless of why
you're outdated or regardless of making sure opinion is nothing much you your
a
framework and so one of
the hippies I believe
and I do believe and I do consent to propositions that are
game and they're very happy with them.
I'm not playing pool and so they don't know what to do about.
That is definitely a far right.
All right.
Then
maybe
that's convenient,
so it's easier to demonize.
That is to again,
more
rights
in our family.
Stress is
certainly not the case.
The reason that I'm very pleased about it,
promoting
the weapons of the state,
certainly more nobody's met
how
you
know
each day to day you have
no.
You
use his art on the wall.
Was
it
just.
I don't know what happened is exactly what I'm thinking of.
The most powerful
way to gain
the story.
Her
name
is
4 million people want hard to sustain,
sustain,
total
opposite,
but
this is
the statement that
was first of all he wants
is
an innocent.
I'm not saying I'm like,
Whoa,
will you
not
be in
opposition
if you're and you're not
that
the packard,
then they're independent party and so so far span and the consequences said
world needs and then the rest are
still very stressful.
You I very.
For
some
of you
written pieces,
how is it
making
sense
so far?
This
last
the
stuff then
radical.
The third one is
all the support needed me and videos and
then they posted that an idea was the balance,
but what happened was
to say
it's more guarantees me,
she
changed her pattern
where
you're trying to do something in the two
zero.
She
was really scared
so
my
nipples
and
goal in
selling
and so that was
so long
ago.
She's real.
You have to do with seeing new
in,
but no means is there is anything
you leave now I can serious
know if I don't get it and I believe that's fundamentally moving across the that
yeah,
Boston substantially more than giving me
a
position where if
they were going to ask.
So what I need the video is a theme.
I thought
I the
decisions
Eric.
No,
I didn't think this
was
absolutely school.
I am still doing.
Which
rules
have.
These
are
all
discussing,
you know,
American
re
continue.
You can always get better at listening and so I've listened to.
I'm not good at that.
I would give that courtesy
still.
Sometimes
you
go
and
you need
good enough
and it's
way more aware of your
cro
that's happening.
Then I have a whole store that they each
get
system healthy
way
so it's like Jasmine
ordinance
stories,
but every time I tell the story,
my
like
idea of games.
Who would be ideal?
Going shoulders.
I know those are the same thing.
That's why I still don't really know.
I know this
stack each
but also
so you been
that
if
you're afraid of.
And then delivering a talk,
you can
reach
out
and
I listened.
I'm not
your
watch.
People
use it.
Well,
I haven't got that
all
wrong.
You
shouldn't be
sorry.
You don't know.
No,
no,
no.
You haven't.
You should know like
knowing
the
area
around
delivering depaul.
No,
in
real life
what the consequences.
That's what thinks is normal.
Pre
and post with water pollution.
Describing what?
Here's the problem and this is
going to have a war and see what probate cases.
Grant
grant already knew
she was right,
not
packs and
he just started
on the journey and that's not
own
for the architect
to
the
rule
in
rule three
different people
who are very fearful
and
very,
very
bad.
It's like you're not happy.
You're bitter about
working
way from sharing the good news take to the shop.
Stop.
None
of that.
So you.
Yeah,
so
learn
how to
say
here's the
consequences
and be the consequence.
Both his brains out in the bunker,
under related in Europe is on fire.
What was the motivation?
Suicidal apocalypse.
That's how do you generate a map?
How do you get profitable and stayed in that matter anymore?
Thoughts and get to an agreement after the self means and you let your
imagination run wild.
You become a mask and that's it.
And it wasn't like a date after World War One was grooved.
Riverside creative capacity.
I find every decent artwork measurement lost all their savings and
it was rotten.
Terrible.
And it was just the Guy and knowing that
is loosely
resentments and eight.
Yes,
we lost him.
Yeah.
Logan is
stories.
It's
so the
reason that I'm doing that.
Why do you
cycle
radical Islam?
The sovereignty
consistent.
Yeah,
and I'm.
I'm
overwhelming.
You have
to make this all work.
I knew I
didn't do it.
We'll see.
Thank
you.
Well,
having said that,
with all these superhero movies,
more
expensive,
most
expensive.
That's
interesting.
Driving communication world big process
and so what are.
What's happening is something far more significant.
I think
we froze our butts itself.
Forms and
generally that's the thing.
They're hearing boxes.
We started with cities and the kids
were
genuine.
Being
genuine
in rowing.
She said,
we'd
say,
well,
Mrs
will
about
on
building their own kids to read six books
that
and
things,
but it wasn't to drive to the store
the
past.
Thank you.